all right let's go to jonathan in
rochester new york jonathan what's going
on man
yes how are you guys doing today
outstanding what's up
great so i got a question so i graduated
from college in may of 2019
i've been working since and ever since i
was like 16 i've been giving money to
my advisor and just straight mutual
funds um so i got
quite a bit saved up there i got about a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars
nice you had a mutual fund when you were
16
yeah i started um my parents had an
advisor and i started going to him
and i just have listened to him since i
was a little kid because i figured
hill he's 20 years ahead of me and i
just said not
if he's in my position what would he
want me to do and i've just always
listened to him
make sure you hug your parents every
time you see them okay
so yeah and then so um i still live at
home and my mom
just kind of told me that kind of a good
blessing they said that they want to
give me
two hundred thousand dollars to put
towards a home
is that their buyout is that their nice
way of saying dude you gotta go
yeah get out of the house right um so my
question
now so how obviously the housing
market's a little hot right now
so do i sell some of the mutual fund and
completely pay off the house
right i can probably get a really nice
house here that i would really be happy
in for about 300.
do i sell some of the mutual fund to
just be totally
debt free or house um free yet um like
that or do i keep some invested with a
hundred thousand dollar mortgage which i
could comfortably afford to pay
um i don't know what you guys would
recommend jonathan any of the mutual
funds they're not retirement based right
it's not it's not a roth or an iron
straight up broke it straight up
brokerage yes straight up brokerage run
i don't have any iras 401ks or anything
like that all of my money
has been just in a straight brokerage
fund since i've been a kid
so if if you were to buy a two hundred
thousand dollar house what would that
look like
it wouldn't i would have to put some
money into fixing it honestly
no no it's fair i would need to spend
about 300 to be
something that i would be and if i do
that i mean some of my buddies i mean
they're all roughly graduating now too i
graduated college in three years
so i had my year ahead of a lot of my
friends and a lot of them were saying
they would move in
so i mean i would wouldn't be covering
the mortgage by myself that's what i'm
trying that's why i
kind of yeah i don't know and how much
income and how much income do you have
how much do you make a year about 115
and 120.
okay so honestly if ire jonathan i mean
either way
there's probably not a right or wrong
because you technically have the cash
just to go ahead and cash out the mutual
funds buy the house outright
and then you have the time you have the
time to invest
because of how young you are so to catch
up on any kind of compound interest
you're going to be able to do that
very very quickly so there's something i
love about the idea of having a paid for
home jonathan
22 22 years old man and then you have
the rest of your life to invest
that's almost where i would go um but
you but knowing you have an emergency
fund and you do have some savings in the
bank
yeah i know i have emergency oh yeah i
do um and that's why the only reason it
was great is because like you can get a
rate for
two and a half three percent right now
and i know a typical mutual fund will
give me significantly more i know
yes yes totally so the math so if you
chose
so we say that a mortgage is the one
type of debt i won't yell at you for
and so yeah if you put down 200 get have
a hundred thousand dollar mortgage and
have the goal to pay it off
in 18 months and say and then you have
the mutual fund there all that
it's just kind of like which way you
want the the money to be if that makes
sense so there's something i kind of
love about the no risk no debts
that's just fun for me i mean obviously
we're we're ramsey so we're going to
kind of push the
i love the no debt i love the no debt
idea right um
because of how young you are and how
much time you have left to invest
and jonathan i moved to nashville a few
years ago
and i didn't have a mortgage until
recently and i can tell you at this
stage of life
i got two kids i'm married dude i want
no
i'm with rachel i would go into being my
23rd birthday owing nobody anything
with a 300 000 paid for house and the
rest i get the math
and you wouldn't be where you are if you
weren't really smart
and really savvy the challenge for you
is to
understand the wisdom of the psychology
of this not the math part
you've got the math part and you're
going to look at the the roi on
the the interest rate versus this and i
can cover the gap there
i'm telling you right now there's
something to being completely debt free
owning your own home there's a
psychology to it man i'd be that's
that's radleen absolutely
congratulations man you were way ahead
of the game brother